ich sag noch mal hallo ist auch in der
sontheimer habe ich schon gesagt meine
kollegin bärbel höhn wir wir schon
gehört haben
wir sind vom schreibzentrum der lmu und
wo wir heute ein bisschen reden wollen
ist das thema leid schreibt prozesse von
studierenden begleiten und die wir nicht
das schreibzentrum werden wir sie nicht
gleich auffordern würden ein bisschen zu
schreiben als sie würden die bitten mal
kurz ein stift und ein zettel zur hand
zu nehmen es ist vollkommen egal was für
eine art stift und zettel das jetzt ist
geht es
und was wir gerne machen würden wäre ein
phocuswright inc
[Applaus]
ein fokus writing dass es eben eine
lehrmethode die eben mit schreiben zu
tun hat ist so eine art freeriding wo es
einmal darum geht einfach mal drauflos
zu schreiben ohne sich gedanken darüber
zu machen dass das irgendjemand später
liest also keine angst sie müssen das
danach nicht vorlesen
es geht nur darum einfach mal ein paar
assoziationen aufzuschreiben und zwar zu
folgendem thema meine studierenden
begleite ich in ihrem schreibprozess in
dem wenn sie jetzt so ziehende sind wenn
sie selber studierende sind dürfen sie
gerne dazu schreiben meine dozierenden
begleiten mich in meinem schreibprozess
indem einfach mal so zwei drei minuten
aufschreiben was da so einfällt einfach
drauf los
noch eine minute
mit
wunderbar dann nehmen wir gleich den
gegangen weil es ab schlussgong für
diese methode wie gesagt ich frag jetzt
gar nicht mal direkt nach kann man
natürlich auch machen was da jetzt steht
aber ich möchte es einfach mal so stehen
lassen da gibt es nun mal um
assoziationen zu bekommen ein bisschen
anders vorwissen ranzukommen sind
wahrscheinlich alle explizit sowieso
schon alle haben diese und alle weiteren
methoden die wir uns ausgedacht haben
eben zum thema schreiben will ihre
integrierten stimmen gar nicht haben
mich alle ausgelacht wie manch nach und
nach soll mehr sie gegründet und neu
interpretiert vielleicht gibt es auch in
dem band beschreiben die integrierende
im rahmen von unserem artikel
traumprojekt und trocken habe ich schon
mal durch genau so als thematische
einstieg prokrastination ist ein großes
thema gehe ich mal davon aus dass kennt
der eine oder die andere von ihnen
vielleicht sogar im eigenen
schreibprozess aber vielleicht fiel auch
von studierenden schon mal gehört also
wenn man sowas hat wie diese zwei jahre
die man zeit hat für zum beispiel eine
doktorarbeit wo eben dann erstmal
richtung world count so gar nichts
passiert eine ganze weile lang bis dann
hier die deadline in sicht kommt und auf
einmal geht so der worldcom so
exorbitant nach oben
so nach dem motto the best inspiration
ist die deadline sehe ich auch wirklich
etwas ganz wichtigen faktor beim
streifen an
aber so muss man wenn man ehrlich ist
jeder der das schon mal gemacht hat weiß
eigentlich dass das großes problem ist
woran liegt das dass man wirklich diese
schreiben auch der stark vor sich
herschiebt da muss man sich vielleicht
auch mal gedanken darüber machen was da
eigentlich erwartet wird von so
studierenden oder promovierenden was sie
eigentlich tun sollen man sagt immer
setzt sich halt hin und schreibt klingt
natürlich recht simpel wenn man sich
jetzt aber anguckt was eigentlich alles
zu diesem akademischen schreibprozess
gehört sieht man na ja vielleicht ist es
gar nicht so simpel also man muss zum
beispiel bei der literatur wissenschaft
kultur wissenschaft philosophie
theaterwissenschaften geht's erstmal ums
lesen oder sehen
oder in naturwissenschaften vielleicht
eher ums betrachten von gewissen
gegenständen objekten aspekten dingen in
der welt dass man da überhaupt erst mal
richtig lesen und gucken lehrern
sozusagen dann analysieren und
interpretieren ist natürlich ein großer
punkt den man da können muss thesen
formulieren argumente finden
recherchieren dann das was man
recherchiert hat dann überhaupt mal
auswerten und anwenden dann in der
arbeit und dann das akademische
schreiben selbst also alles was stil ist
richtig zitieren eine logik finden den
roten faden finden das sind alles die
anforderungen die wir an unsere
studierenden stellen und da braucht es
natürlich auch eine gewisse art der
betreuung also wir müssen diese schreibt
prozesse begleiten und nicht wenn wir
mehr machen wollen als nur zu sagen
letztlich hin und schreibt natürlich was
wir haben vier punkte vier ebenen
sozusagen mit denen wir eigentlich
schreibt prozesse wirklich begleiten
können das erste ist die fachlehrer
offensichtlich das zweite die theorie
des schreibens das dritte die begleitung
von schreib projekten und das vierte
riding two day also die integration von
schreiben in die lehre
da würde ich jetzt auch zu den einzelnen
punkten gerne ein bisschen was erzählen
und zwar erstmal zum thema fachlehrer
ist natürlich unser kerngeschäft als
dozierenden klar ich bin
literaturwissenschaftlerin was würde ich
meinen studierenden weitere bringen
literaturwissenschaft natürlich also wie
analysiere ich einen text wie bearbeite
ich den mit welchen fragen die ich an
diesen text heran
und das ist eben das was wir wo wir ja
eigentlich angestellt sind
dass wir unser fach einfach nach vorne
bringen das ist super wichtig das will
ich auch überhaupt gar nicht in abrede
stellen die frage ist nur können wir ein
bisschen mehr machen oder sollten wir
ein bisschen mehr machen wenn wir am
ende dann erwarten dass die leute eine
gute arbeit schreiben das zweite ist
eben die theorie des schreibens und zwar
bei der theorie geht es eben einer weil
es darum dass wir uns selber als zu
ziehen denn mal fragen wie schreibt man
eigentlich also welche theorie wie
funktioniert schreiben dass videos
selber überhaupt mal wissen und das
zweite dass wir es auch ein bisschen
transparent macht
also wie können wir in den einzelnen
kurse neben den leuten auch ein bisschen
klarmachen was schreiben eigentlich ist
wir gehen eigentlich immer vom schreibt
produkt aus also was am ende da stehen
soll und der denken dann ja macht es
halt und dann wenn es dann vor uns liegt
gut oder schlecht und dann gibt es die
note drauf beschreibt didaktik geben wir
mittlerweile viel stark stärker von
einem prozessorientierten system aus
also dass wir sagen wir gehen nicht von
dem schreibt produkt am ende aus sondern
schreiben ist ein prozess der länger
dauer der hat mehrere stufen und genau
das braucht eben das wo wir reingehen um
das leben zu begleiten
und da sollte man vielleicht auch mal
wissen aus wasser stets hohen
schreibprozess eigentlich der ideale
schreibprozess beginnt natürlich erstmal
damit dass man thema hat thema bekommt
oder findet der zweite punkt wäre dann
zu diesem thema ideen zu generieren
als nächstes diese ideen man hat ja
meistens ein wust von irgendwelchen
zetteln post-its alles möglich an
experten was man so finden konnte
eigenen analyseergebnissen und so dass
man das ganze einmal strukturiert und
das dann im rot xten mal in einen einen
text verschriftlicht um dann am ende das
ganze noch einmal zu überarbeiten im
idealfall bevor man wirklich abgibt so
ideal jetzt kommen wir zur realität die
sieht er so aus dass man eben sagt man
fängt mal an hier mit den ideen
generieren dann fällt dann schreibt man
vielleicht war es dann geht man zum
strukturieren zurück dann fällt ein
irgendwie ein oh ich habe eine neue idee
muss ich vielleicht doch noch mal zurück
springen dass es eigentlich so er die
realität aber es gibt auch noch dieses
hier was ich gerne das schreibt chaos
nennen dass man einfach irgendwo ansetzt
und dass man sich selber eigentlich mehr
damit blockiert weil man in den
einzelnen phasen eben immer hin und her
springt also sowas der klassiker man hat
gerade den gedanken und denke ich oh das
schreibe ich jetzt mal auf dann schreibt
man so und dann fällt man ja wie
schreibe ich jetzt eigentlich das wort
noch mal okay ich schau mal schnell im
guten noch nach dass man da sich
eigentlich aus dem gedanken schon wieder
raus gehauen hat weil man dann meint
jetzt muss ich mal gucken was sie ziert
die richtige schreibweise
dass man dann eben nicht in diesem einen
blog mal bleibt und mal versucht ich
schreibe jetzt erst mal den gedanken hin
und schaue danach dass ich dann über
arbeiten kann
also das wäre eben das problem vom
schreibt chaos was dann oft dazu führt
man hat dann vielleicht ein rotex und
hat man keine zeit mehr und dann gibt
man direkt ab ohne das ding jemals
überarbeitet zu haben ich glaube jeder
von uns hat seine arbeit schon mal
selbst verfasst oder gelesen wenigstens
ein weiterer punkt der auch noch ganz
wichtig ist dass man davon ausgehe dass
es verschiedene schreibt typen gibt ja
dass nicht jeder gleich schreibt und
auch nicht jeder gleich schreiben muss
er also es gibt strategen die särge plan
vorgehen die dann eben sagen ich habe
einen plan den arbeiter ich ab und so
komme ich dann durch die indiana jones
ist unter den schreibern also mehr die
abenteurer die die neben mehr so
drauflos dass die sagen schreib einfach
mal wo ich gerade lustig bin problem
kann natürlich sein dass da vielleicht
die ordnung und die die gliederung so
ein bisschen verloren geht der springer
hüpft einfach sagen hoher gerade spaß
hat kann natürlich in so einer
aufschieberitis enden dass man die
schweren aspekte überhaupt gar nicht
erst an geht der zehnkämpfer hat so mehr
versionen hier schreibt ja er schreibt
zb 5 einleitungen sucht sich am ende die
beste aus und der lektor ist so einer
der eben sehr oft wieder wieder drüber
geht überarbeitet das sind meistens die
besten die saubersten arbeiten wo man
sich einfach freut weil es so schön
flüssig zu lesen ist ohne dass man
irgendwie alle kommafehler korrigieren
muss ja und es ist eben wichtig dass man
selber mal überlegt welcher schreibt bin
ich eigentlich welcher schreibt typ sind
meine studierenden dass man überhaupt
weiß dass es verschiedene gibt gibt
natürlich auch mischformen ja dass ich
auch mehrere sachen sein kann aber es
ist eben wichtig dass theoretisch auch
mal so ein bisschen zu durchdringen also
insofern immer wichtig selber mal
reflektieren und gleichzeitig eben auch
transparent machen dass die leute über
sich selber auch ein bisserl was wissen
dass es lustig wenn man das studierenden
erzählt und die dann gleich so war das
hat mir jetzt geholfen dass das okay ist
wenn ich so schreibe
also das ist auch oft einfach seine
motivation ist geschichte der dritte
punkt wäre jetzt die begleitung von
schreib prozessen also das ist ja schon
was was besser oder schlechter
funktioniert meistens mit dozierenden er
also die einen die sagen halt neujahr
gibt es dann halt irgendwann ab andere
sagen ja ich möchte dann vielleicht mal
ein exposé sehen oder ich möchte mal
irgend eine leseprobe sehen oder so da
gibt es auch eigentlich von bis zu
ziemlich alles aber es ist natürlich
wichtig diesen dieses schreibprojekt was
die studierenden haben auch wirklich zu
begleiten
zum beispiel mit sodingen dass man den
bei der themenfindung hilft also das
geht ja oft einfach schon los so was ist
denn eigentlich ein thema im vergleich
zu einer these oder eine forschungsfrage
das ist ja oft schon gar nicht klar
also da sollte man halt auch sich ein
bisschen gedanken darüber machen und in
der methoden sammlung sind eben auch
mehrere methoden drinnen wie man so was
machen kann wie finde ich denn jetzt zum
beispiel ein thema
ein beispiel was ich hier raus genommen
habe jetzt das blitz exposé des blitz
expo sie geht ebenso dass man eben diese
vorgefertigten fragen hat worum soll es
in der arbeit gehen was wollen sie
herausfinden was wie mögliche ergebnisse
also das sind alles einfach so
leitfragen die in einer halben stunde
oder in 20 minuten oder eine
viertelstunde einfach mal ausgefüllt
werden sollen möglichst schnell da geht
es auch nicht darum dass das jetzt alles
schön aussieht es geht einfach nur mal
darum ideen dazu zu finden gibt auch
noch mehrere verschiedene sachen also
nicht nur auch zur themenfindung sondern
auch im späteren schreibprozess alles so
in dieser methoden sammlung mit drinnen
wichtig ist einfach dass man die
studierenden schon bei diesem prozess
ein bisschen mit anleitet dann ich habe
jetzt auch bei profil ist ein
projektmanagement seminar in der lehre
und da habe ich auch noch was ganz
wichtig ist mitgenommen
und zwar habe ich mir dann auch gedacht
ist ja nicht nur gut wenn ich das weiß
wie es geht sondern auch wenn die
studierenden das ist ja also projekt und
zeitmanagement tools er so ganz banal
eigentlich sich mal zu überlegen ich
habe einen gewissen zeitraum in dem
dieses projekt entstehen muss mit einem
gewissen ziel wo ich hin will
wenn ich jetzt eben bachelorarbeit ich
habe im moment wieder vier bachelor
kandidatinnen wo
eben jetzt auch einen ein kleines
treffen hatten wo ich ihnen genau das
gezeigt habe wir haben für in der
bachelorarbeit zehn wochen zeit um diese
bachelor arbeit zu schreiben also ich
oder diejenigen gehen also ich nicht
habe ich nicht mehr aber ich eben als
schreiben da hab eben zehn wochen zeit
und muss eben in diesen zehn wochen
irgendwie zurechtkommen
damit es die mit dieser prokrastination
nicht so läuft sollte ich mir vielleicht
vorher mal gedanken machen wie das mit
der zeit so aussieht also wenn wir jetzt
einfach mal diese verschiedenen schritte
im idealfall mal nehmen sieht man schon
dass die einzelnen schritte eigentlich
gar nicht so viel zeit brauchen dürfen
ja also wenn wir sagen recherche zwei
wochen lesen konzipieren drei wochen
ausformulieren zwei wochen und dann noch
einmal drei wochen
also einfach nur wenn man es mal
wirklich zusammen nimmt das ist mal die
eine sache das andere ist was passiert
wenn man zb dann noch mal ein wochenende
zum ski fährt ja hat man auch wieder
keine zeit dann ist man vielleicht
einmal krank und einmal muss man dann
noch ein referat halten oder dann ist
geburtstag oder keine ahnung irgendwas
oma hat ihren 80 oder wie
da muss ich dann auch irgendwo anders
hin fahren und schon geht es ganz
schnell dass wir ganz viel zeit einfach
für andere dinge verplant haben wo wir
nicht schreiben können
das muss einem im vorhinein natürlich
klar sein also insofern so ein bisschen
zeit management projektmanagement auch
an die studierenden weiterzugeben ist
ganz zentral damit der freiheit prozess
überhaupt funktioniert genauso das
feedback also wie gesagt es gibt leute
die da fast gar nichts machen und andere
die machen mir ganz wichtig finde ich
schon dass man an den schreibprozess
versucht wirklich nah dran zu bleiben
weil gerade heutzutage wo wir das
internet haben wo eben auch viel einfach
mal so unreflektiert übernommen werden
kann auch nicht unbedingt absichtlich
sondern auch vielleicht einfach nur aus
unwissenheit oder zum beispiel auch dass
es heute institutionen gibt die eben
auch auftragsarbeiten annehmen wird zum
beispiel bachelorarbeiten ist es schon
wichtig dass also man als dozierende
möglichst namen schreibprozess daran ist
damit man auch einfach den merkt wie das
ding entsteht und wo man eben nicht sagt
naja das wer weiß
die arbeit wie mit was entstanden ist
insofern ist es schon auch von vorteil
wenn man sich so meilensteine mal vor
nimmt ja dass man zum beispiel sagt man
ja zu dem zeitpunkt sollte dann mal eine
gliederung eingereicht sein dass man da
auch feedback geben kann drauf oder auch
so was wie eine leseprobe einfach mal so
ein zwei seiten
und da ist es natürlich auch sinnvoll
wirklich feedback zu geben natürlich
korrigiere ich nicht die ganze arbeit
durch aber es ist natürlich schon
sinnvoll wenn ich sie also passen auch
bei den zwei seiten hast du keinen roten
faden bis 100.000 rechtschreibfehler
drin und zitiert hast du auch nicht
richtig das ist natürlich besser wenn
ich das in diesem stadium sagen kann als
wenn es dann nach der abgabe ist und
dann ist das geschrei groß wenn dann die
noten nicht stimmt also klar muss man
immer wieder sehen ob die leute das auch
annehmen aber ich kann das vorher schon
mal intervenieren und schon mal sagen
okay da müsste man so ein bisschen
aufpassen und der letzte punkt wäre auch
noch so motivation weil natürlich
schreiben auch eine sehr emotionale
sache ist und das ist also wieder
teilweise die bachelor kandidaten
kommende eine riesenaufregung das ist
ein riesending was man da zu tun hat und
dann muss man sich vielleicht auch ein
bisschen rein versetzen ist es natürlich
sinnvoll ab und zu mal so ein kleiner
pep talk ist nicht das was also was
jetzt da nicht hilfreich wäre sondern
ich glaube schon dass da manchmal die
studierenden da so ein bisschen zu ihm
aufschauen und dass die einfach freut
wenn wir mal sagt ja das wird schon das
schaffst du schon
und kann man ja auch mal in einem e-mail
zum beispiel verfassen weil sich zum
beispiel auch gerne macht ist so eine
kleine schreib sprechstunde wo ich
einfach sagt an dem termin bin ich mal
so eine stunde da und dann können alle
kommen und dann kann man auch ein
bisschen feedback geben man kann man
darüber reden aber als ich das letzte
mal gemacht habe war das sondern auch
ganz nett die wollten dann eigentlich
nur hören das ist alles gut ins und
alles alles was sie auf einem guten weg
sind und es ist auch ein selber
teilweise effizient weil man dann
wirklich auch die leute ein bisschen
bündeln kann als wenn die eben alle dann
immer
mails kommen will was ist da was ist
denn da und wenn man ihnen da eine
schreib sprechen gemacht hat man da auch
schon wieder zeit gespart wenn dann auf
einmal fünf leute da sind wo man dann
halt so klassiker zum beispiel auch noch
mal diskutieren kann
als letzten punkt und eben auch ein sehr
wichtiger punkt wo ich dann auch gerne
weiter dann abgeben möchte an diversen
radio zum thema integration von
schreiben in die lehre
da geht es uns eben sehr stark um dieses
prinzip des constructive weinend weil es
ist ja eigentlich schon abgefahren ich
vielleicht sage ich erst mal kurze
definition in constructive alignment wie
stark wird die haut kam
also die idee dabei ist eben dass wir
das was die leute können sollen danach
eben mit dem lehm mit der lehre
zusammenbringen
wir müssen das lehren was am ende auch
abgeprüft wird und es ist natürlich so
ein bisschen widersinnig wenn die am
ende eine arbeit abgeben müssen und
alles was wir in der lehre machen ist
referate halten zum beispiel dass es
halt alles fachlehrer was gut ist aber
am ende ist dieser schritt wie kriege
ich die fachlehrer aufs papier ist
eigentlich was wir nie betrachtet haben
also insofern diese anbindung von dem
was wir lehren zu dem was wir am ende ab
prüfen ist ein zentrales thema und da
kann man natürlich jetzt sagen so ja so
viel zeit haben wir ja überhaupt gar
nicht aber wir haben natürlich eine
lösung für dieses problem hin
mit diesem ansatz freising zu lernen wo
es eben darum geht dass man auch
überschreiben sich inhalte erarbeiten
kann und dass man das in die lehre
integrieren kann und da ist ulrike
scheuermann auch eine eine figur die
eben darin die richtung auch arbeitet in
ihrem buch schreibt denken hat sie eben
da noch mal darauf hingewiesen wie
wichtig es ist schreiben als denk- und
lärm werkzeug zu nutzen und zu
vermitteln und das ist eben genau der
ansatz wo dann unser multiplikatoren
projekt vom schreibzentrum ansetzt und
darüber gebe ich dann gerne an dich
jagd und wurde kurz erwähnt eingangs ich
trage es vielleicht noch wichtig kurz
behinderungen
genau danke basterds wurde wie gesagt
2015 gegründet und ist auch aus diesem
programm lehrer lmu entstanden aus den
verschiedenen förderlinien zusätzliche
tutorien wir haben gesehen es gab
ambulante schrag tutorien und
verschiedenen fächern und da ich das
studium beruf und seiner fakultät für
sprach- und literaturwissenschaften
leiter haben wir uns gedacht wir bündeln
das schreibzentrum zentral an der
fakultät das schreibzentrum es dann auch
ihre schnell gewachsen auch über die
grenzen der fakultät hinaus inzwischen
haben wir über 50 prozent der
studierenden die fakultäts fremd sind
sozusagen
wir haben 14 4 toren eine davon ist
heute darüber auch hier die bei uns die
beratung übernehmen und das ziel ist
eben eine fachübergreifende
kompetenzentwicklung im bereich des
wissenschaftlichen schreiben
es ist wichtig schreibt prozesse zu
begleiten das hat sabrina schon gesagt
nicht nur damit dozierende auch bessere
seminararbeiten zu lesen bekommen
sondern natürlich schreiben für den
studienerfolg absolut unerlässlich aber
auch für den späteren beruflichen erfolg
also jeder wird in seinem beruf auf
irgendeine art und weise schreiben
müssen da noch passiert eher selten es
gibt studien die zeigen auch tatsächlich
das 89 prozent der studienabbrecher
sagen dass ihre seminararbeiten mangelt
mangelhaft betreut wurden und das ist
auch ein grund war weshalb sie ihr
studium abgebrochen haben es ist also
ganz wichtig und so gewinnen dann auch
keine große überraschung dass so
schreibzentrum so gut läuft wir hatten
im wintersemester erstmals über 1000
studierende die die angebote des
zentrums genutzt haben
die da wären individuelle beratung durch
eben schreibt ihr tutorinnen wir
organisieren schreibt tage völker einen
im semester freitags workshops jeden
freitag haben wir mittlerweile zwei bis
drei workshops weil wir das angebot gar
nicht mehr die nachfrage gar nicht mehr
abdecken können unser riesenevent die
lange nacht der aufgeschobenen
hausarbeiten kommt immer sehr gut an
über 300 studierende die sich immer
gemeinsam im lehr ton treffen zum die
nach durch treiben
wir bieten schreibt gruppen an das sind
zwei autonome schreibt trifft eigentlich
wo studieren dass sich austauschen und
nach eigenen regeln treffen über ihre
schreib projekte sprechen
das ganze ist für studierende und
promovierende und auf englisch und auf
deutsch einige englisch native speakers
auch im team
darüber hinaus gibt es auch noch kurse
die kann man bei uns über das breit und
nebenfach sprache literatur kultur
belegen eine einführung ins
wissenschaftliche schreiben wir machen
immer wieder workshops und seminare auch
zum journalistischen zum kreativen
schreiben jetzt ganz neu kooperieren
auch bei veranstaltungen wie der lange
abend des literarischen schreibens mit
der volkshochschule und haben so ein
relativ breites portfolio inzwischen
auch ein zertifikat schreibkompetenz mit
dem der jetzt im wintersemester starten
witzigerweise gelten schreibt zentren in
deutschland immer noch als irgendwas
innovative ist mit rollenangeboten also
ich bin der amerikanistik in amerika
gibt das bürgertum frühen zwanzigsten
jahrhundert schon weiding centers und
sind wirklich fest etablierter
bestandteil einer hochschule und zwar
vom community college bis nach heirat
also man möchte auch nicht als
nachwuchszentrum verstanden werden das
ist völlig selbstverständlich das
schreiben dazu gehört gerade auf dieser
ansatz dieser trina erwähnt hat raiding
to learn was dort oft in weiding erste
coaching programmen aufgefangen wird
eben jedes fach kann auch schreibend
vermittelt werden und man lernt in jedem
fach das fachwissen auch durch schreiben
also selbst mathe kurse werden mit
selbst in mathe kurse beschreiben
integriert also nicht nur in unseren
fächern genau
ich war dann auch in den usa letztes
jahr haben wir ein paar allerdings etwas
angeguckt in new york in chicago weist
auf einer großen schreibt didaktischen
konferenz und fand es sehr spannend wie
was für ein selbstverständlicher teil
schreiben dort aus in der hochschullehre
fand es aber am interessantesten eben
zusehen jenseits der arbeit vom
schreibzentrum oder von riding centre
ist die ja immer fachübergreifend sind
und unsere freitags workshops sind super
aber das ist immer auch eine
trockenschwimmen übung immer geht einmal
freitags hin und hat sich etwas dazu an
klar kann man das auch selbst
reflektieren aber schreiben jetzt immer
fachspezifisch und sollte eigentlich so
nah wie möglich am fach gelehrt und
gelernt werden
und das kann man eben auch wann hört
diesen ridinger taste kiel und dort war
eben so der tenor ratings it be a part
of any case that which also egal was man
unterrichtet man sollte irgendwie doch
auch schreibend vermitteln was man macht
hier nochmal unsere flyer der auch hier
glaube ich überall ausliegt wenn ich
kann man sich gerne mitnehmen auch gerne
an alle studierenden weitergeben
wir haben vorgestern die workshops
freigeschaltet die ersten sind schon
voll
ich glaube der renner ist diesmal the
german riding college und also für
internationale studenten sich erst mal
darauf einstellen müssen was an einer
deutschen uni zu erwarten ist dann haben
wir eben gedacht wir rufen dieses
multiplikatoren projekt ins leben zur
integration von schreiben in die lehre
wir sind ein relativ großes team ich
würde mal sagen aktive mitglieder sind
etwas weniger um das jemand abzubilden
wer eigentlich alles beteiligt ist und
haben dafür eben verschiedene bausteine
entwickelt
der erste baustein war eine lehrenden
befragung also wir haben von einem jahr
417 lehre glaube ich erreicht die
tatsächlich in so einer basis umfrage
teilgenommen haben zum stellenwert von
schreiben in ihrer lehre welche
bedürfnisse welche herausforderungen
sehen sie was sind ihre erfahrungen
haben danach dann auch workshops
entwickelt wo man mit lehrern gemeinsam
diskutiert und überlegt welche methoden
zur integration von schreiben in die
lehre sind haben ein haben eben diesen
methoden band entwickelt und auch ein
balding volle programm ins leben gerufen
und zudem können lehrende in class
workshops buch und ich würde es nur so
einfach so zu jedem dieser punkt zu
sagen
eine wichtige frage also die
schreibkompetenz eines großteils der
studierenden die ich unterrichte ist
erfahrungsgemäß naja befriedigend
irgendwie mittelmaß interessanterweise
niemand hat sehr gut angekommen
also man scheint schon zu erkennen dass
es da so einen gewissen bedarf gibt die
meisten waren dann auch der auffassung
dass es das schreiben eine zentrale
rolle spielt in anderen sprache der
literatur wissenschaftlichen studium und
dass die verbesserung der
schreibkompetenz der studierenden durch
gezielte angebote wirklich dringend
notwendig ist
hier auch noch so ein bisschen die
bandbreite der einschätzungen im
freitext manche sind der auffassung nach
schreibkompetenz kann nicht zu den
erlernbaren inhalten im studium gehören
dass studierende die mit dem zeugnis
über die hochschulreife an die
universität kommen sich in angemessener
form korrekt schriftlich ausdrücken
können sollte selbstverständlich sein
wir haben damit nichts zu tun auf der
anderen seite in meinen augen ist das
wissenschaftlich schreiben in jedem
lehrveranstaltung typ im bereich anderes
geisteswissenschaftliches studium
integrieren es fährt sich die frage ob
man bereit ist kapazitäten dafür
bereitzustellen also da ist schon die
frage hin wie sollten das auch noch
machen ja das kostet alles zeit manche
sehen uns einfach nicht als ihre aufgabe
schreiben zu vermitteln
ich war mit christus ist ganz auffällig
dass wir diese starke trennung
vorgenommen wird zwischen fachlehrer
fachwissen und der vermittlung von
schreibkompetenz mal so die beiden
scheinen überhaupt nicht kompatibel
miteinander zu sein und hier auch wieder
das in den normalen kursen einfach keine
zeit für diese dinge ist
weitere wünsche geäußert wurden schreibt
module die zur verfügung gestellt wurden
die zur verfügung gestellt werden
sollten lehrende sollten sich mal
zusammen setzen sich austauschen eine
offene runde
ich bräuchte konkrete ideen nach anlass
wie werfen mit bezahlten teaching ostern
für in americana die auch helfen beim
feedback und beim korrigieren von
arbeiten und ja überhaupt feedback holt
sich überhaupt niemand mehr was konnte
man da eigentlich machen
unser erster schritt war dann eben die
entwicklung von dieser methoden sammlung
also wir haben wirklich versucht lehrer
und dann ganz konkrete übungen methoden
an die hand zu geben wie man schreiben
relativ ressourcenschonend in die lehre
integrieren kann und eben auch zu
vermitteln dass inhalte damit vermittelt
werden also es geht nicht darum
schreiben also als extra zeit noch
einzuplanen ins curriculum sondern
einfach durch das schreiben inhalte zu
vermitteln und damit nebenbei als
nebeneffekt praktisch auch schreib
routinen einzuüben mit studierenden
diese methoden sammlungen kann ja können
ja alle vielleicht ein kurzer blick
reinwerfen ist so ein bisschen auch
aufgeteilt in orientierung recherche
phase ausarbeitung zwar um diese
prozesshaft ich kai theben darzustellen
beim schreiben
die dauer ist von wenigen minuten bis zu
einer vollen stunde die man mit diesen
methoden füllen kann das ist alles
relativ finden wir einfach zu
integrieren in kleinere lerneinheiten
auf spalt war vieles ist auch
austauschbar und das meiste davon ist so
genanntes lospech riding also ein
schreiben im kurs zum beispiel das nicht
benotet wird also wo studierende auch
ohne angst schreiben können und
vielleicht gibt es friedberg vielleicht
nicht aber vielleicht können wir dazu
auch später noch diskutieren dann genau
das war die methoden sammlung gebe
zwar schon gezeigt genau schreibt ein
stimme schreibt gespräche als nächstes
haben wir dann zwei workshops einem
januar ein im mai dieses jahres
durchgeführt mit lehrerinnen von
insgesamt 35 lehrende teilgenommen
die sich interessiert haben für die
integration von schreiben in die lehre
haben dort auch noch mal so eine best
practice börse veranstaltet wo eigene
erfahrungen eigene methoden nochmal
eingebracht werden konnten die wir dann
wiederum in unseren in unsere methoden
sammlung aufgenommen haben fand es
eigentlich sehr produktiv ich glaube
viele fragen und zweifel konnten da auch
aus dem weg geräumt werden also ich hab
gar keinen fall dafür ich kann kein
feedback geben
ich kann so was gar nicht wie wie soll
das überhaupt gehen also ich fand es
eigentlich sehr produktiv und wir planen
auch weitere solcher workshops
anzubieten auch vielleicht einen anderen
fakultäten war so die frage genau
und dann haben wir eben dass es ein
etwas umfangreicheres programm des
riding verlobt programm ins leben
gerufen das ist auch etwas was aus den
usa kommt natürlich aber mittlerweile
auch schon ein paar schreibt man in
deutschland erfolgreich etabliert wurde
raiding verlauf sind speziell
ausgebildete schreibt ihr tutorinnen die
oft auch schon mehrere jahre erfahrung
haben als beraterin im sprachzentrum die
eben ein fachseminar begleiten das
schreib intensiv umgestaltet wurde
das heißt im rahmen von diesem seminar
müssen studierende nicht erst eben
ausgelagert in die semesterferien
sondern schon im verlauf des seminars
zwei oder drei kleinere schreibaufgaben
bewältigen und bekommen dann eben vom
riding hallo feedback auf diese
schreibaufgaben das kann in der gruppe
seien individuell schriftlich das muss
man einfach mit dem lehrenden abstimmen
wichtig geben schreiben als prozess und
was ich eigentlich einen total
spannenden effekt für eine von diesen
baldigen volle programm ist dass
lehrende ganz explizit machen müssen im
austausch mit diesem rating fellow was
eigentlich die erwartungen sind die sie
an dieses fertige produkt haben und das
ist eigentlich der mehrwert wenn ich
wirklich von diesem programm dass
lehrende viel stärker reflektieren
müssen was sie eigentlich erwarten was
sie von den studierenden wollen
vielleicht sogar mal ein blatt ab
tippen müssen oder dass dazu angehalten
werden oder der riding palo hilft dabei
so ein erwartungshorizont oder sowas zu
formulieren und so ist der ruhigen
verlauf eben auch mittler zwischen den
bedürfnissen der studierenden und
erwartungen der leeren dann gibt's die
mehr kommunikation über das schreiben in
diesen kursen auch und am ende bekommen
wir bei problemen arbeiten du kannst
vielleicht dazu auch noch mehr so genau
[Gelächter]
beschreiben gemacht haben
das feedback an solcher betrag zwischen
1 und 5 was würdet ihr sagen habt ihr so
im vergleich zu anderen kursen lernen
verlieren es wirklich auch als als
bereichernd empfunden haben dass man die
ton genutzt um eben auch die noch leben
weiß ich auch interessant finde das
sollst du einem wenn man schreiben wenn
die lehre integriert automatisch das
diskussions niveau irgendwie stark dann
studierende erstmal über eine frage
schriftlich nachdenken und reflektieren
und sich dann erst melden und den mund
aufmachen kommen da meistens sehr
sinnvolle sachen bei raus ich fand es
wirklich ein schöner effekt der letzte
punkt wenn die in class vorschau so
lehren die jetzt kein raiding falle
wollen oder nicht so intensiv schreibt
intensiv ihre lehrveranstaltungen
umgestalten wollen können auch einfach
mal für 30 minuten oder 45 minuten einen
schreibtisch des zentrums buchen an
einem termin ihrer wahl
die inhalte werden genau abgestimmt ob
seine um gliederung und struktur geht
oder themenfindung oder leserführung
also wie finde ich den roten faden das
ist dann eigentlich eher wie so ein
kleiner freitags workshop aber im rahmen
von einem seminar seminar zeit auch hier
habe ich auch in amerika mitbekommen
spricht man so von stealth tactics also
dass man so heimlich die lehrenden auch
mit schuld praktisch wenn man diese wenn
man diesen angeles workshop gibt weil
sie immer auch erfahren
die eigentlich das schreibprozess
studierende funktioniert welche fragen
vielleicht auch studierende haben und
das thema einfach da auch noch mal auf
den tisch kommt genau es vielleicht als
ausblick noch wir wollen mehr
fachspezifische lehrenden workshops auch
veranstalten wir hatten anfragen zum
beispiel aus der linguistik dass man mal
so ein schreiben in die lehre
integrieren workshop nur für den größten
veranstaltet schön wäre natürlich wie in
den usa diese kury chorale verrannt
verankerung von schreib intensiven
kursen dass man sagt es gibt ein
bestimmtes module und da gibt es immer
schreibt intensive kurve und jeder
lehrende opfert sich halt mal die wir
unterrichten und integriert daneben
schreiben intensiver viele haben ja auch
spaß machen dass mir macht das auch
schlecht war
wir wollten auch noch mal schauen ob man
in studienordnungen also unterhalb einer
reform schauen kann wo man schreibt
intensive lehre stärker verankern könnte
in welchem semestern in welchen modulen
das sinn machen würde und suchen
natürlich auch den
fakultätsübergreifenden austausch also
und auch sucht immer neue mitarbeiter
also wer lust hat sich am schreibzentrum
zu engagieren und mitzuarbeiten kann ich
jederzeit glaube ich gerne anfertigen
kein geld ich weiß gar nicht wie haben
keine zeit mehr nach wir hatten
abschließend noch nochmal eine methode
die machen wir jetzt gleich gar nicht
aber ich sage es ganz kurz das kann man
auch ganz einfach immer am ende das
seminar von nominal sitzung einsetzen
will matthias freund und bequem ist
freund wo studieren da einfach noch mal
zwei minuten aufschreiben was aus der
heutigen stunde fand ich überhaupt
völlig unklar und es mir noch nicht
bewusst geworden wo habe ich noch fragen
und bequemes freund diese idee finde ich
super das nehme ich mit und das habe ich
verstanden dass konnte man jetzt so als
feedback machen aber vielleicht steigen
wir einfach direkt mit marias freund und
ließ und in die diskussion ein oder
genau
vielen dank